[Music]
you know what blows my face off I've
come to realize kindness from others to
others something I realized recently is
how excited I get when I see somebody do
something i watch this actually happened
I watched like a young thug looking kid
let an elderly woman you got your
perspective hey guys welcome to a new
episode of my podcast I mean I rarely
have somebody on my podcast twice
there's just too many [ __ ] people to
get to and let's call what it is I want
to be speaking all the time anyway
that's why I interrupt everybody and so
I'm even sad when I have a guest let
alone somebody who actually is [ __ ]
coming on for the second time but
however somebody I've admired for a long
time you'll you know you'll be able to
go back with google his name and my name
and the same thing you'll be able to see
the first time we were together thought
there was a really strong episode of ask
Gary B since then some of you may know
we started speaking bureau I stole my
favorite employee favorite partner this
guy right there on instagram pew looking
Zack Nadler from CIA and we started
being her speakers and the gentleman
that's with me right now is actually
part of that world and at least from
what I'm seeing on my PNL I think he's
probably happy and made a good decision
which is an awesome thanks Ryan but more
importantly way more importantly why
we're here he has a new book out I think
you're
during his nine book I was commending
the size he made a brilliant statement
which is what he does about you should
read it in one flight I think that's
right I've just cut 800 pages of my next
book out and and he's 800 I'm kidding
I'm joking
Oh actually my next book no joke is most
likely gonna be a textbook Wow
so I've been so much in you know what I
see yeah and I'm actually trying to help
learners that learn differently that
don't do what I do like daily thing
whatever so nonetheless that's not we're
here for stillness is key
Ryan holiday is in the building Ryan how
are you thanks for having me I'm awesome
happy to be here happy to have you
excuse me all right what's what's when's
the book coming out yesterday so came
out yesterday probably it's live on
Instagram so go to Amazon type in
stillness is the key buy it if you like
me at all but for everybody's listening
now I'm probably putting this out in two
or three days what-have-you it's
obviously now on Amazon and all your
favorite bookstores what's it about
right well it's about this idea of
stillness which might seem like you're a
strange person to talk to about
stillness because you're the most active
hardworking person that I've not only
met but maybe heard of but I actually
think that people miss what stillness is
we think stillness is like a monk or
it's meditation stillness is what you
have to what you need most when you're
super busy and active right do you
actually believe because your screen ly
thoughtful that I'm wildly still wildly
still I don't know about that but here's
what I would say please for all the
activity and all the things you're doing
there's no way you could be as
successful as you are if your mind was
going the same speed that your body is
like like if a really great athlete in
the in the craziest busiest game super
slow it's slow the game has slowed down
they're seeing things that everyone else
isn't seeing when it's amazing you said
that because I was a big sports fan when
that first hit the lexicon um when I was
9 10 13 17 when I heard great athletes
talking about the game slowing down yeah
when I tell you how slow everything feel
for me I often say to my friends that
New York City slow for me and they
always freak and they're like you are a
crackhead yeah and and what I'm actually
saying is what you're actually talking
about everything is so simple everything
is so slow mm-hmm everything is the same
pattern over and over and over again I'm
scared to tell people how slow it feels
yeah because and I think I think it's
not just athletes I think great stock
traders great artists great whatever
what when you reach mastery and what
you're doing not only does stuff slow
down but it simplifies and so you're
able to make connections that other
people can't make you're able to control
your emotions in a way that other people
can't control them so when they're
scared anxious worried frustrated you're
like this is what it is let's make the
most of it like when I I think about New
England and the Superbowl being down 28
to 3 that is what stillness is even
though they then in like the next 12
minutes listen you know I love you of
course we did all the nice things up
front I'm aware that Coach Belichick is
a fan of a prior book you've written hmm
but for you to have the audacity to drop
that analogy in my face for all the
belief that you are one of them kindest
most thoughtful kids I know I I forever
feel about you differently okay okay
well let's go out of track let's more
let's think about a running back as the
the space opens up which is super narrow
right and on the one hand you'd think
they'd be worried about getting hit you
think they'd be worried about the clock
know all that they've they've zeroed in
on this thing they have it's funny you
say that to make myself feel better but
it's actually true I am and I've watched
a lot of Pittsburgh Steeler football
because just being in playoff runs and
things that nature it now that I'm
watching every one of his runs in in the
short couple games that Le'Veon Bell has
played for the Jets I do not recall a
run this everything about his success in
the NFL is now completely obvious to me
and it's actually completely predicated
what you said his shuffling his
pitter-patter at the
which is outrageously patient and his
I'm fascinated how he runs the ball I am
too and look let's zoom out there's also
I think an amount of stillness and let's
call it confidence required to make the
decision to hold out for a year right
like what brings him to the Jets like so
imagine what people are saying about him
on Twitter what's being said in
negotiations what his family what fans
don't know about it and his contract and
by most standards is okay for the
holdout but let's just go to a different
place even higher up to your point
judgment is so rampant in our society
sure the people that cast judgment have
envy of a professional athlete because
let's just call it what it is a shocking
percentage of us would want to be doing
that however people are so undereducated
on what football players are going
football players are not basketball on
baseball players these are not
guaranteed contracts people are wildly
confused by the actual math and one hit
it's over and one hit it's over and so
that idea of being able to tune out all
the stuff that's happening around to
stick with a principle or to it just
stick with what you think you need to do
for your career so Ryan in my obsession
of I mean I assume discounted this is
somewhere between 11 and 18 bucks on yes
on to make that why for the masses that
are listening to me right now like and
us when I say to you
like I'll there are so many things I
like about you mmm-hmm and I think it's
and it's honestly I think it's the
things that I see similarities would
come at it differently but I just like
the way you do [ __ ] when I ask you this
question because it's how I always think
what why is $13 gonna be really good for
somebody on the other end sure there's
always a lot of answers yeah but on hot
take what's your answer to that question
you mean generally with books with this
note this book to what you know about my
audience I was just thinking about this
way I make good money I can solve for
big sports teams I consult I give talks
to big organizations I spent three years
working on this thing this is three
years of me thinking
every single day kommen history combing
sports combing literature for the
strategies and insights for how the the
Great's of all time slow things down and
get to a place where they're not jerked
around by their emotions or jerked
around by external noises when you think
about that why for you as a human do you
not take the process that I do which is
put out content along the way for free
why does it manifest in this form for
you I do that like so I write every
single day I write an email called daily
stoic that goes out to 200,000 people
and it's the biggest community of people
interested in ancient phosphene when are
you starting the text version of it the
I use the same come but I just signed up
with the same company I mean you did
yeah great
I think that's the next question expert
you're about the [ __ ] do you know what
[ __ ] your pants looks like I'm a
fortunate lino okay so I think I think a
lot of people are on the like ish
business of [ __ ] their pants right I
think it's really hard if you're in a
like to be fully [ __ ] your pants
really let go or unconscious but I think
a lot of us secretly we don't want to
admit it but there's a lot of people in
this room on the stream and in life are
in the ish of [ __ ] their pants
business so in that I don't even know
where I'm going anymore you're about to
shoot your pants when you see the data
behind what texting sure actually means
an actual consumption well what I'm what
I'm really into so you know you write a
book and and I think the daily Stoke
books sold like 600,000 copies it's in
30 languages it's crushing huge number
but I like I saw that book to a
publisher who sells that book to Amazon
Amazon's now responsible for 80% or so
above sales of so they you basically
sell your book to him that wasn't a joke
you think it should be higher no I don't
think it should first of all don't think
anything should second your guess would
be higher no I think I mean that's a
pretty ridiculous thing it's a joke to
everybody who competes against Amazon in
selling books of like why the [ __ ] have
you guys not in
they did in 20 years it's terrible it's
a bookstore with me I do I think we rush
I have an idea about all I actually have
one okay guys this is how it happens
yeah no really
in Lincoln to nap years you're gonna see
and by like in 11 years because it's
just a thesis that then will be
contextualized in 11 years but we have
the general knowledge yeah what we put
it into there's a real by the way
there's a huge play to go against an 80%
market share of Amazon especially
because Amazon as awesome as they are at
this point doesn't really care that much
about books like I bet books men 1% of
us revenue yeah you mean as a yeah a
hundred percent they're in the place
where the financial aspect of it won't
dictate them too fast follow in
innovation yeah yeah and so so my point
is I saw a book to a publisher they sell
to Amazon Amazon sells it to customers
that works as far as books go but the
problem is I'm two three steps removed
from owning the relationship yeah with
the customer which is the key thing the
only thing and that's Oh with daily
Stoke it's the email list we sell
products directly to the consumers the
margins are better but more importantly
like when this book came out I could
send a flyer to 30,000 addresses in the
US like that because I control the
relation my reason for writing books
somebody asked me the other day is
because I don't want to be audacious in
the way that I learned oh I can't learn
from reading this book right and not on
the record yeah you're not a you're not
a book guy it's just not how I know it's
not my I'm clearly have reading
disabilities that I'm not aware of cuz
the eighties we didn't really diagnose
but but others learn like it's crazy to
me that people send me emails that
they've learned more in reading crushing
it the emails like thank you for writing
crushing it I've watched every video
you've ever put out but it was crushing
it that made me do that I'm like mother
[ __ ] really like it really you know and
so like not being audacious on how one
learns or consumes yeah it's such a
framework of how I think about it well
authors I think we get this sort of
target blindness right like an author
things like I'm an author that's what I
make and then they're like so I don't do
podcaster I don't read emails are you
you had you sell ideas and you got a P
and I think I think the huge thing
there's so many people now that are
reading that thought they didn't like
books because it turns out they don't
like reading books they love audiobooks
right they love ebooks they love courses
they just didn't think they liked this
packaging matters yeah of course I love
this this is what I live and breathe for
but I can't let me eat a lot hundreds of
you hundreds a year like this is but
that's what I do
that's cool so like you constantly or
are you the kind that reads like three
books at once and you're back and forth
or you like alright I'm gonna read this
book I'm always reading one book with a
pen like I was reading a book in the car
on the way here
and I'll finish that tonight I'll start
another one like like literally when you
just said that I was like oh man I would
be in the car reading eight hundred
comments yeah it's just so funny how
everybody has I love that I love that
okay so that's it so you just believe
hey I I myself believe that I'm good at
synthesizing I'm good at hypothesizing I
spent three [ __ ] years on this and
for the people that consume information
this way this should crush for them I
think so and then what I've taken from
you is like okay so my preferred medium
is books I get the book out now I have
to break the book back down into
podcasts videos emails social because I
got to reach back out to the people who
consume in different mediums what else
can we educate people on about the
subject matter or any anecdotal stories
or anything funny about them so I think
people think stillness is meditating I
don't meditate it's not who I am a too
much energy it doesn't work for me and
so people go because I don't meditate
there's so many other ways to get to
stillness you can journal I think
everyone should take a walk every day
right I think people should is boring as
[ __ ] well I do all my phone calls
walking I don't sit in my office I walk
so I think you should do something or
hate nature
you gotta love nature man why because
there's animals have evolved to have a
connection with nature don't know I
respect the [ __ ] out of nature but if
you're not in it you're there there are
like objective
health benefits to like experiencing
things that are green the Nora - watch
might be drilling cancer into your arm
right now thank you like sure like where
I'm really going is I don't like
actually I love nature let me change my
mind okay
I don't like seeing things okay I have
this deep not want to see I don't give a
[ __ ] about the pyramids okay I
definitely don't like beautiful trees in
the Pacific Northwest
I don't that's right at you Caleb I
don't care about like look all the
[ __ ] New Yorkers go [ __ ] wild when
the sunset goes down some [ __ ] Avenue
or Street not I have an inherent non
interest in seeing things okay
like I like talking to but like laying
in my bed on with my you know the iPod
you know earpods is more interesting
than like if the walking people can talk
about the health benefits of the steps
and that's fine a lot of people I'm I'm
so happy like so many my friends and
relatives love a good [ __ ] walk
mm-hmm like just are like walking down
the beach or like walking on nice little
trail just genuine and short like my dad
if he sees a [ __ ] skunk run across a
[ __ ] grassy knoll hey my dad loses
his [ __ ] mind for a turkey popping up
behind a good-looking [ __ ] oak and
I'm like who gives a [ __ ] but what what
is that for you many things I love
watching people mm-hmm interact with
each other that's where you get your
energy like connect you know what blows
my face off I've come to realize
kindness from others to others I'm
something I realized recently is how
excited I get when I see somebody do
something I watch this actually happened
I watch like a young thug looking kid
let an elderly woman cut him in a line
at that McDonald's at the Chicago
Airport if everybody knows I'm talking
about there's out I love travellers
there's that one McDonald's that's right
in the middle where you have to [ __ ] it
like so you know it I I was like there
I got stuck I had a problem with a
client so I was like you know I'm
walking which I love walking in an
airport because I can watch people be
nice to each other instead of a [ __ ]
you
no [ __ ] [ __ ] people like my dad sees
a chipmunk won't run across like the and
he's like look I'm like what anyway
nonetheless I watch the kid thug life
thug looking kid and i think you know
i'm i love thug life so like this was a
thug looking and say ma'am why don't you
cut me yeah and i can't stop thinking
about it's been [ __ ] 100 days yeah
that's the best that's what I that's my
that's what I okay I like I like
watching people do the right thing by
people okay I don't get enjoyment out of
like stuff like I don't know I don't
know why like there's literally a
website enough that the if the URL
expired doesn't take a look
I think it's Gary Vee hate Gary Vee
hates mountains calm yeah yeah I hate
him
do you uh Jimmy hobbies yes I love to
garage sale yeah I know that but that's
it's that is that a hobby for you or is
that just another extension of what you
already do it's another extension of
what I already do so advocate Jets
I like watching sports is your hot so
after the Second World War
Churchill wrote a book which you would
not I would say Churchill's the busiest
most most successful man the twenty
percent that we've hung out five or four
times ever talked about Churchill what
are you talking about being dead [ __ ]
serious when we sat way you ready when
we sat in the [ __ ] theater at
something that summit you brought up
Churchill did I yes you did let's go
ahead he writes a book called painting
as a pastime and it's it's a book about
the power of hobbies and he says that
like the most important thing that a
busy powerful person can happen says you
got to have at least one or two or maybe
three hobbies because you exhaust your
mind doing the thing that you do and you
have to have an outlet for the energy
because that's what makes you great but
it has to be different you know what's
funny about that it's why I am so
obviously a huge sports fan I have no
control and I'm completely it's the
bizarro version of myself as a sports
fan I'm emotional mom ninety four point
seven percent of my fights on Twitter
have been with Patriot fans ninety four
point seven
there's also nothing else you would do
that takes four hours for yourself
correct other than go to a Jets game
it's the complete reset of my life yeah
that Sunday resets every
all eight thousand four hundred thirty
seven issues mean nothing to me the one
knows for hours sure I think I think
Golf is actually I don't like golf but I
actually get it because it's the only
excuse that a CEO has to be gone I see
out of the office for four hours it
makes sense and so you got it I think
people think like I think music does it
for people yeah I think video games do
it I see it all the time
you got to have your thing and you got
to realize that that thing is actually
helping you be better at your intention
of what I already do I would argue when
I really break down garage selling it
isn't now that I'm going back and forth
the thrill of rolling up on a street
with a pearlescent sign and not knowing
what's about to be in that person's yard
sure knowing that I might find a 1954
Green Lantern cereal box like the thrill
of the hunt my process I don't want it
like I want to try to buy the Jets more
than I actually want to own them like
the thrill of the hunt is my high yeah I
don't think actually owning the Jets
would be that fun I think it's the well
to be super fun when I beat the [ __ ] out
of the Patriots Ryan of course I got
something for you are we wrapping up
yeah alright so I was telling you about
about Jimmy Rock Oh Zach you're on
interim life alright Zach you look at me
thank you putting your phone number
right now we're about to call one of you
to answer a question so start throwing
your phone numbers out I'm gonna hack
pin one and then read it to me we'll
call you the minute or two I got either
coin last time but if I know I thought
you'd like this this is this is what I
wear it's a signet ring it's the same
thing memento mori' your favorite words
remember you will die I love this about
you yeah and then on the inside it's
from Marcus Aurelius is you could leave
life right now and the idea is this
could be the last conversation this
could be the last day you show up to
work you'll ask garage-sale you go to
could be your last jets game and so this
idea of like let's let's [ __ ] do it
then let's be actually leaving that [ __ ]
me too
I believe in that [ __ ] the most people
think thinking of your mortality is
morbid but it I think it's the the way
you embrace life fully I think about it
every day here's a crazy one so this
Joey but for real the Stoics say when
you tuck your kids
in tune into bed at night this thick
this is crazy I get its controversy you
go they might not be here in the morning
I think about it every day I do too
I think about every single day having a
massive tragedy mm-hmm I think about
very often my wife and kids in a car
getting a tree landing on them and
killing them all in one shot and what is
that what do you do with that
information I act as if yes yes so you
don't hold on I'm walking around and
looking at them every minute all the
time at the macro yes I'm grateful it
leads the gratitude totally and it means
oh I don't need to rush this I don't
need to rush this is there is their
theory where's their tactical reason mix
up to both yeah yeah and is that
important to you based on the weight
like I think a lot about that for me I
think way too many books are like here's
an idea
figure it out right and you got a give
an idea and then you got to tell people
how to make that idea real something
I've been really trying to push is like
watch what I'm doing like I'm not
necessarily gonna make a white paper
like that's not my skill and though we
have done well we put out a video
recently we did a deck I really want
people to watch it's so right there yeah
it's right there just why did I post
that right like why sure nothing is by
accident yeah I'm not like [ __ ] dick
talk well I think that people do they're
like give me the 1 2 3 stuff and it's
like if it was that easy there everybody
value it yes of course
Nate what's up you're on the podcast
with Ryan holiday amen we're doing well
how are you what's your question
[Music]
[Music]
right on what the take is on thanks for
callin brother the take is what do you
think about playing video games for a
living I mean if you're great at phone
call yeah Suzie fired phone guy good
look I think if it's if it's what you
feel like you were put on this planet to
do I think it's a great thing to do for
a living I just think oftentimes people
are attracted to things like sports or
video games or writing because they
think it's easy and the point is like
and there's like yeah the point is
actually it's ridiculously hard it's not
only ridiculously hard but because so
it's so hard only a very few amount of
people get to do it right so unless you
really were put on this planet to do it
and you have a deep burning drive to do
it it's not going to happen the utter
non conversation around talent yes it's
fascinating to me sure yeah because it's
because it's crippling right looking at
somebody saying you know like we've what
do you think I think it's awful like
look I hear from people to go I think
about writing a book I'm like okay don't
you know what I mean it's like it's like
I have to write this book if I don't it
will be physically painful that's a
reason to write a book right it's like I
have to start this company because I'm
so angry that X is the current status
quo you got to have a reason why do you
think so many people live their lives so
deeply in need of affirmation of others
including strangers well I think
evolutionarily we we need it nobody
wants to be outside of the tribe but
people I think a lot of this is like
look I I think if I'm successful my
parents will like me if I have lots of
Twitter followers like I can get dads
look you know there's I think it's a lot
of it's a childhood thing you're trying
to recreate where they were in high
school or you know some it's some
childhood thing they're they're
recapturing which is a bad reason to do
anything did you speak to Ryan yet
a JB just walked in for podcast piece
anything good on being her sports a JV
there we go
putting in work I love it I want you to
speak to AJ real quick yeah uh yeah I'm
just there's so much interesting [ __ ]
going on bro of course I'm so tired of
judgment I just like stability to
judgment is on tilt right now I'll be
more obsessed with judging I was I gave
a I was at stand up New York with James
Altucher last night and someone I said
something about Trump and this woman got
up and she's like I don't think it's
fairly er doing this I'm not gonna make
it Trump thing what I what I was saying
what I was so surprised by is that she
gave a [ __ ] about my opinion I was like
if you were up here and you were saying
something that I disagreed with
politically you know what I would think
about it nothing because I don't care
what you do and I don't care why like I
don't get people who are upset about
Le'Veon Bell contract negotiation it's
like it's his life you know I mean like
people have these super strong opinions
about things that don't affect them
because it's a way of not having to look
in the mirror about the one place that
people make a connection point that a
this person has control yeah you know
lady I'm Belle to your right that's why
that gets to the most extreme yeah right
because people do think it has control
people do think there's collateral
damage yeah you know and I have been
petite for that I think your points
taken though and where you're taking it
we're we're just judging the listen in
the history of the human race anger and
digging your heels in has never been a
solution and we're just [ __ ] pulling
apart on every [ __ ] issue but it's a
tear it's a terrible strategy when you
actually look at people who have created
profound change it's always flawless of
empathy love and and what they usually
they don't go look how awful they whine
calm
they don't go look how awful these
people are look how terrible things are
they go these are the principles we all
share let's live up to them together and
here's how you might have gotten there
and here's how I've gotten here and
let's joust on that yes not you're a
piece of [ __ ] right you're irredeemable
you're awful because you can't come back
for me
90% of America saying you're either a
communist or a racist yeah which is just
not true yeah of course not and how did
once you once you call someone that or
once you put how you come back yeah
amazing thanks for anyone anyone the
comments are gonna come in right now
who's the three to one [ __ ] if I was
[ __ ] born in 3 2 1
that would definitely be my like I want
to hear it all day that's all my
behavior I'm only living for that I
appreciate it
please say please say hello to Ryan
[Music]
what's your question to get it for free
yes you can pirate it off all the sites
do you so why don't you go audio of
course of course it's like 30% of market
at this point good whatever works yeah
100% a deep where we're deep real quick
be right D where's the 3 2 1 area code
where's that number from
well then email me
it's Gary a vaynermedia and we'll do it
again if you get if you give up three
two if you give up after emailing me how
many how many D I'm gonna look D don't
lie because I'm gonna put you on [ __ ]
blast how many times have you I love it
[Music]
you're trying to hack me be your tagging
me on [ __ ] that is even relegate me Oh D
I do know who you are
D I know exactly who you are your tuck I
you're talking you mean when I'm talking
about putting out a a song every single
day
d D D D let me get in here let me get in
here T's let me get in here I have good
news for you I actually know exactly who
you are your photo is a real up-close
like your content has your face real up
close know not only doing your best all
right D you're gonna answer a very
important question this is now the
moment right because you got through
this call I don't know how you trick
Zack ah you've done such a good job that
I know exactly who you are so think
about that now you guys deliver here's
the moment this is going to be the
variable if it happens or not be very
thoughtful here are you an Orlando Magic
fan that's good now step 2 of this game
who do you like
[Laughter]
Alex had me call this crazy woman
tomorrow Zach will give me the number D
I'm gonna speak to you tomorrow
I [ __ ] love you okay I me too
thanks T good job Zach
that wasn't me Ryan thanks for be on the
show everybody's watching and more
importantly buddies now listening and
I'm sure somebody's listening to this
two and a half years after this came out
I think one of the things I admire about
Ryan is this just this [ __ ] brain
that's just the truth and and what I
know about that that means without
knowing and this is like the only
cosines I've ever given books if you
read the seven or ten times I've ever
done it I'm saying it about the person
not the book cuz I'll never read the
book what I can guarantee you is if
you're listening to this on April 17th
2094 you should go pick up the whatever
version of how you consume communication
at that point in the pelvis yeah please
swallow the pill it's called the
stillness is the key see ya
Ryan thanks for going on
you